Josh what's up buddy you're muted by the
way
um do you have a mic
yeah I got Mike don't worry yeah okay so
something about liver king and a plug
yeah I can't remember I don't know what
it's called but I remember seeing on his
Instagram
that I think he's when he was at a hotel
because it was like I don't know if you
I don't uh
I can't honestly remember for the life
of me but I know it has something to do
with improving your sleep is it a third
attempt
yeah one of those attends okay so if
it's a tent that you put over the bed
it's probably like a faraday cage yeah
yeah speaking of it what do you make of
him
make of liver King yeah
that guy's foolish well okay
absolutely 100 on [ __ ] gear he's not
Natty don't [ __ ] lie about it the
problem is is that guys like him Michael
Hearn The Rock they're so far and so
deep into the LIE they can't rescind it
it's like I'm Natty I'm Natty I'm Natty
they can't ever say that they're not
right so they're way too far down the
rabbit hole they can't [ __ ] admit it
but he's clearly not [ __ ] natural
like any expert that's looked at him has
has said this [ __ ] is not
natural he is on gear okay so there's
that and then there's a question about
AB implants too and I was I was watching
this one thing because like when you
move
you know your abs kind of move like they
twist with you yeah but there was a guy
that did an analysis on it and it's like
he's always sitting there without his
shirt off so you can see him in every
[ __ ] pose and it never moves right
um so it's either AB implants or the
other Theory they have is is I did AB uh
sculpting where they basically go in and
they do like liposuction between the ab
muscles to kind of accentuate that AB
segment
um yeah but I don't believe for a second
that you can just eat Bowl balls and
[ __ ] you know lift weights and just
stand in the sun all day with your shirt
off and grow a long beard in your hair
and you'll be a [ __ ] god like
the dude's on gear he's lying about that
and you know the stuff about the ABS I
don't know I mean the only way that you
can tell is if you do an ultrasound in
that area you can buy an ultrasound
device and you can scan it and then
you'll see a silicone
you know like implants so if he wants to
prove that he doesn't have AB implants
then he would do that but you know why
would you if you're scared of that
uh yeah
I've got another question yeah
well some TV shows you recommend any guy
watch
um
for me like like Breaking Bad
so I liked uh Vikings peaky blinders
um I like shows that portray men in
masculine roles conventionally masculine
rolls Yellowstone
um
that's the stuff that I watch like as
soon as I turned something on and
there's some woke purple-haired [ __ ]
like in the wrong place at the wrong
time because Hollywood wants to put it
there for progressiveness I just turn it
off okay that's why a lot of people like
shouting in anime as well
don't watch it
um but but back to the point of like
that that Faraday cage that tent I mean
that's a bit Overkill
um would it help with your sleep would
it eliminate the EMF a little bit more
possibly but I mean now you're getting
into nerd Zone like you can walk into my
bedroom and you would never know aside
from the chili pad cubes that are at the
end of the bed
um that there's anything different in
the room right but when you start
putting like weird metal tents over your
bed as a faraday cage I don't know I
mean that's just not for me I'm not
going to go quite that far mm-hmm
make sense yeah it makes sense all right
Josh thanks for popping in no worries
bye see ya hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out